So you understand focus and
you understand semantics,
two crucial pillars of accessibility.
To wrap things up, let's spend
some time talking about styling.
Now this is a broad topic,
but I'm going to try and
segment it into a few important areas.
The first is ensuring that our elements
are styled to support the accessibility
of work that we've already done.
This means adding styles for
focus and various ARIA states.
Once you've got that squared away,
we can look at how to make sure our
UIs are flexible, and
can handle being zoomed or scaled up for
users who may have trouble
reading smaller text.
Lastly, I'll talk about color choices,
look at the importance of contrast and
making sure we're not conveying
information with color, alone.
So there's a lot to cover.
Let's get started.